and as always some kind of feedback or
if it's not through it through the show
it's at the end so it's in the challenge
of waiting to see what is the response
going to be at the end or then you have
it all through the performance which is
another feeling that you get too is so
it's totally two different ways of
Performing when you have it that way but
when you have a very quiet audience you
sort of make sure that you get your
point across in your delivery and
everything is is it is best but when
they are rooting and tooting for you
then you just sort of just have a good
time with it you don't have to be so
correct you know
[Music]
I've been doing it too long to be
nervous
if my dress wasn't right or my shoes
wasn't right you know but everything is
fine and I know the words so I'm gonna
be fine you can't replace what's live
you know it's it's one thing looking at
it sometimes I say I really wish it was
possible that I could just really take a
seat and look at my own shell because I
I don't want to look at it on screen
it's different it's being there and
seeing that that human being standing
right there actually doing it and not
that he was a month ago or that it was
photographed my idea is that when you
look on the stage and you see that
actual group there it's like oh that's
another whole different feeling
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
it's almost like anything that's a
classic blast I mean it's still good
there's knowledge behind it there's
Roots there's experience and the
difference is uh when the younger
generation and your era goes to see
current groups and you come and see what
to someone like Rad or myself or Rolling
Stones and you see that difference the
difference is that we know what we're
doing we have mastered it and we're just
playing around with it now where
everyone else is still beginning to
master it I can't really tell you the
future that I wish I did know the future
you know if I did I haven't I might just
take the world right away with it you
know but I learned more of whatever
there is to learn and just keep giving
it and and because that's what the whole
thing is about is to give and to give
people enjoyment and so whatever it
takes you know whatever the knowledge
comes is what we'll be given
[Music]